let's get in that first big story we got
from timcast.com illinois governor gave
300 000 of federal relief funding to
black lives matter this is
three hundred thousand dollars in
federal covid 19 relief funds went to
the lake county chapter of blm
i could not when i saw this you know
what i wanted to do i went on twitter
and i was like what do i tweet and i was
like oh i know i'll tweet are you paying
attention wait oh my god no i can't
tweet that for not only does jackpot
tweet that for everything i'm like i
think he just we're paying attention now
especially if you're following me on
twitter so i just said i'm not even
gonna ask i know you're paying attention
it's this bad let me pull up their
official documentation this is covid19
relief funds check it out your business
was shut down you're in massive debt
you're getting evicted from your house
your business was burned down a riot so
money was taken from your tax dollars or
printed and borrowed and the democratic
administration from the federal
government gives it to the states
and then illinois says we're going to
give a right back to blm here it is
right here look at this under the guise
of criminal ju of criminal justice and
crime intervention black lives matter
got 300 thousand dollars
when we talk about january 6 when we
talk talk about the federal government
going after only one political faction
letting the riders do whatever they want
barely prosecuting anybody going after a
bunch of magamimas who were let in the
capital and then you can see they're
directly funding them
you know what maybe they're reason not
going to charge any of these riders with
terrorism because then they'd all
basically be committing some kind of
sedition and insurrection and then they
would be ineligible so when when they
when they sued madison medicine cothor
and saying he couldn't run for
reelection i tweeted out kamala harris
is ineligible to run for public office
because she engaged in insurrection
against these united states by providing
material support to those engaged in
insurrection and terror against this
country amen so blm is kind of the
perfect scam here because there are
absolutely no results needed what are
the strings attached to when you give
them money what are they going to say
it's part of what's brilliant about this
kind of political activism generally
speaking the worse the problem gets the
more they can claim that they're needed
and the more they can claim that you
have to give them money or else you
don't care about the problem on top of
that when it comes to jb i'm not sure if
y'all are familiar with him or if the
audience knows much about him but being
from the state of illinois originally i
can give you a few facts on him that
will uh leave you unsurprised with the
fact that he would mismanage federal
funds in this way firstly he is every
single thing that the left claims to
hate and he's all of them at the same
time it's almost amazing he is a
billionaire trust fund baby venture
capitalist and in the state of illinois
he raised the collective tax burden by
5.25 billion dollars still couldn't
balance the budget he tried to raise it
eight billion but wasn't able to but he
himself does everything he can to avoid
taxes he had a second house which was a
mansion and he had every single toilet
removed from it so it would be
considered uninhabitable when the tax
assessor came and he wouldn't
yes and so he wouldn't have to pay as
much in taxes he's an absolute swamp
creature so so so we could take the
toilets out of here and just put like we
could dig a hole in the backyard and i
don't got to pay taxes yes well you have
to pay some taxes but it's assessed of
as being at a lower value if it's
uninhabited or uninhabitable wow yes
that's that's amazing very slimy well if
there's anything that the government's
really good at it's wasting your money
and scamming people and this is a
perfect example of this where did that
money go to an organization that can't
even account for 60 million dollars as
of course there's ongoing investigations
into blm right now i mean what did you
expect and then i mean there's so many
different consequences here there's so
many different ramifications here
there's so many different ways we could
even talk about this specific story but
this is how the government chooses to to
to take your money that you they save
them they create the problem exactly
then they take your money to fix the
problem and give it back to the people
creating the problem or partly and then
make more problems right right so uh the
president of the lake county blm chapter
clyde
mclamore was arrested in kenosha in 2021
and charged with felony battery of a
police officer so look
you got somebody who is actually
arrested for a violent crime being given
money under the guise of preventing
violent crimes in chicago now innocent
until proven guilty of course always and
with a lot of the stuff going on these
past few years i'm not necessarily going
to just blindly trust cops or anything
like that but yo blm
this is not the first scandal it'll
certainly not be be the last scandal
i i think
what people need to understand i don't
know how to say it
there is a powerful element of the
government that hates you
that is actively funding people who have
destroyed lives and are destroying your
businesses in your homes
and we are watching them do it with your
own dollars yeah exactly they funded an
organization that called for the
disbanding of the family unit they
called they funded an organization that
literally has marxist talking points
that that wants to of course spread
divide and conquer techniques that have
been effectively deployed in the united
states and have worsened race relations
here in this country yeah well it's
funny because i was going to ask the
question could you imagine any
right-wing organizations receiving this
kind of money from the federal
government like the patriot prayer group
but then i realized they're pretty much
entirely employed by the federal
government aren't they yeah patriot
prayer patriot prayer group i'm sorry
what's the organization okay
i'm sorry yeah i don't know about i
don't know what's going on with patriot
prayer guys but uh oath keepers
apparently yeah yeah man
we were talking about this the other day
with julie kelly
where you have all of a sudden these
these people everyone's asking like why
aren't they being charged in the january
6 you know riot and then all of a sudden
they get charged yep because they were
going to be called as witnesses
and now they can plead the fifth
yeah dude very sketchy i just
i i got to be honest though i don't want
to be debbie downer i don't want to be
negative nancy right for some reason we
have these alliterative words
you know depressive but uh
i really do think that we're seeing
these stories
it's exposing what's going on and it
used to be that this stuff happened and
we didn't even know what was happening
around us so
what you got to watch out for is you
know because i felt i fall victim to
this sometimes as well you read all of
this really bad stuff and you're like
man things must be really bad and then i
stop and i'm like actually we wouldn't
even know this was happening 10 years
ago exactly so it's actually
you know it's bad it happened
but we've got investigative reporters
exposing all of this stuff that's pretty
good yeah there's a theory out there is
you know people are asking themselves is
the world becoming a worser place or are
we just finding out exactly how the
world really works and i think we're
finding out exactly how the world really
works and there's consequences for
negative actions for every action
there's an equal reaction that's
newton's third law and even just you
know yesterday we had the indiana
attorney general come out and say that
blm is a scam and he said that the house
of cards is starting to fall as of
course there's major questions about the
60 million dollars that were given to
them by major institutions by very
powerful players and now even
governments not just multinational
corporations pushing an agenda not just
blackrock and the esg social credit
score but but there's so much influence
here when it comes to pushing this
narrative and the unraveling of it it's
going to have equal consequences in my
opinion there's something interesting to
be said about individuals choosing to
donate but the the government funding i
have to wonder if you know i'm willing
to bet illinois is not the only state
that did this absolutely not i'd love to
know to the extent to which you've got
these smaller groups
just think about this
we had riots all over the country it was
not centrally organized not necessarily
it may be through perhaps the democratic
party and like groups like act blue that
were bailing out a lot of these people
but the funding that went to these
smaller groups
in all these different places
where did where did they get that money
from if illinois was giving it to a
local chapter wouldn't would you know is
his government funding them in other
areas i'd have to assume yes and most
importantly what did they do with that
money is the bigger question asked here
and there it could be reasonable to to
ponder that maybe they don't want to
release the records of the 60 million
dollars because now the california and
the washington attorney general are
demanding the financial disclosures of
where their money came from you could
argue that maybe there's even more
governments that were involved here with
the funding of blm that they don't want
publicly released and that's why the
data hasn't been out there do you
remember that there was that guy in
california who had his own group called
black lives matter and he raised like
300 grand on his own and then they went
after him and trying like they destroyed
his life
he he owned it before they did and they
went after him so this was an actual
activist this one's some guy trying but
it was like i repeat myself right but
was was this actually someone who
believed in the cause trying to raise
money or was he so when when blm first
started there was no like centralized
organization or anything so he was like
okay i'll make a non-profit we'll call
it this and his and he said his goal was
to bring the community and the police
together
so that we can end you know this clash
in this conflict right that flies in the
face of what they're actually trying to
do they're trying to abolish the police
so they accused him of being a charlatan
a fraud his fundraiser fundraising was
all suspended they went after his
finances and he was legitimate he was
like as far as i know he was totally
legitimate well that's the thing they
always go say black lives matter is if
that's all they actually want but they
know if you say blm what you're actually
saying is i support this organization
and the reason we know this is because
this guy was literally saying in the
most direct way possible black lives
matter and they said nope can't do that
it's it's time we recognize
this idea of the working class and the
elites and these other classes based on
100 years ago this writings of you know
100 year old dudes is wrong or at least
needs to be updated because how do you
explain these urban unemployed leftists
who are not working class
but they claim to be and they hold these
insane ideologies and they support these
insane cultural ideologies they're not
the truckers are the working class
these people aren't you know like i
refer to them somewhere as intelligent
cause they're college educated but
they're not the intelligentsia they're
not smart people no they're not they're
not writing books and they're not
writing poems and they're not saying i
challenge you they're just walking
around going like tell me whatever to do
walmart they're like the corp the
corporate the corporate npc class yeah
they're repeating statements instead of
creating art instead of creating
entertainment instead of actually
building stuff they're literally just
saying just tell me what to say and i'll
say it tell me what i need to do to to
go along and get this perfect
governmental environmental social credit
score that's going to of course profit
my business and at the end it's not a
stretch to imagine that more governments
supported blm financially because they
supported them in many different ways
whether it's george soros appointing a
whole bunch of attorney generals that
implemented a lot of their policies
whether it's government officials
bailing them out whether it's government
officials literally supporting them
giving them permits to march whether
it's dr fauci and bill de blasio
excusing their mass marches and
mobilization saying that they're good
for the general public rather than of
course attack anyone who was going
against protest against the state that
was bad and that was causing sickness
and covet to spread again there was so
much hypocrisy the state cuddled this
movement and brought it to a very
significant place in our culture that
has had horrible effects on everyone
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time